[Música]
bueno
[Aplausos]
agustí tos como estamos
acabamos de comernos
pues este deporte nacional de la siesta
y ahora admiro un montón porque
como este momento como de recapacitar
reflexionar durante el día
yo creo que en el mundo ahora mismo
estamos como relajarnos cada vez más
sabes cómo entrar en momentos como de
producir menos y estar más en horizontal
pero bueno mi nombre es meneo y me pagan
para manejarlo
así es vamos a ver esto así que señores
esto es una gameboy
estamos adaptándolo aquí a una super
nintendo para que veáis un poco lo que
hago aquí y lo que necesito
es que os pongáis de pie rápido
[Música]
alguien en el aire
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la mano está arriba nos habla desde
arriba
[Música]
lo importante que es tenga una nalga
relajada allá hay una estación de
respiración de nalga nalga por si
alguien tiene una tensa
[Música]
21 23 y
a la canción
[Música]
para que me pagan para que me pagan
y dice así
[Música]
habla a veces
sí
[Música]
e
o
[Música]
pues muy bien muy bien
[Aplausos]
pues sentaros podéis entrar es a nadie
perfecto
que fluya la sangre al cerebro
y bueno yo soy muy psicólogo y es
curioso porque
no sé alguna vez habéis visto un anuncio
de trabajo en planes se busca musicólogo
una cosa como
pero los que están al final de los
conciertos hablando en las barras sabes
esos son los que estaban como
filosofando sobre la música
y ese es mi trabajo de vida hay algunas
cosas que podemos comprobar dentro de la
musicología y hay otras cosas que no por
ejemplo
podríamos decir que la música en el
continente africano está hecha para el
cuerpo sabes como tu punto punto por
punto cultura que la música en el
mediterráneo está hecha para el corazón
sabes cómo
[Música]
y la música en el norte digamos está
hecha para la cabeza
contundencia no
estas son cosas que no podemos comprobar
son como filósofas luego hay cosas que
sí podríamos comprobar por ejemplo
cómo afecta el horario de apertura de
los bares a la hora de escuchar o
componer música por ejemplo estamos en
berlín que tiene una ley que pues puedes
estar tres días con los bares abiertos y
eso hace que los compositores tengan
como minimal en la cabeza sabes que lo
importante será que la música esté sin
subidón es ahí como no tranquilos
hablando no sé qué y luego tiene sitios
como en londres que
cierran los bares a las 3 de la mañana y
a las 11 de la noche ya está todo el
mundo bebiendo todo el mundo a saco el
agua para después a las tres y media
todo el mundo y sé como que lo ha dado
todo
de relajada y a casa son cosas que
nosotros los musicólogos pues pensamos
nos hablan de cómo nos afectan
y yo pues al final de la barra hasta
atrás me da cuenta de que puedo
pronosticar el futuro de la música
basado
los ciclos de madurez de nosotros como
seres humanos
ciclos de madurez como por ejemplo nacer
crecer reproducir tumba la casa y morir
ese tipo de ciclos digamos
afectan también la forma en que
producimos música no entonces quiero que
hagamos un viaje ahora conmigo y nos
situemos cuando nosotros todos teníamos
15 años
15 años digamos que es el momento donde
es tu primer cigarrillo
el primer vestido los chicos malos usan
cuero motocicletas es una época donde la
música sería algo como esto
ahora sí 2
[Música]
y este rollo que tenemos 15 años como
vale perfecto todos los años
imaginaros que ahora pasamos a los 60s
pero nosotros ya no tenemos 15 años
tenemos 20 años hasta los 20 años como
nos damos cuenta un poco de las
injusticias del mundo protestamos por la
igualdad queremos explorar nuestro
cuerpo si antes eran cigarrillos ahora
son zetas y ácidos y nos vamos de rave
sería un poco el rollo como
y la de tu abuela
[Música]
whitelock break contribuciones
entonces en ese momento pues tenemos 20
años y somos como rebeldes
es un poco el espíritu de los sesentas
luego el espíritu de los 70 sería un
poco como que si tuviéramos 25 años es
una edad bastante crítica porque
ya no vivimos con nuestros padres
tenemos un trabajo bastante precario no
tenemos experiencia todavía empiezan
también las desigualdades no vemos que
el estilo es más importante quién está
buena quien se pone ropa quién se pone
y además en los trajes y cosas así
guapas y la música sería lo así como
[Música]
tengo mujer
yo hago lo que yo hago
[Música]
y luego gracias en euros un euro
[Aplausos]
y luego los 80s pues si seguimos está
este ciclo de ir avanzando cinco años
pues tendríamos 30 años y a los 30 años
guay porque todavía no tenemos familia
no tenemos responsabilidades
no tenemos hijos y hay pasta entonces un
poco sería la música como
la extra
[Música]
sueño
no existe
y este rollo de los 90s de los 80s
perdón es curioso porque es como mucha
creatividad no hay mucho dinero en plan
de las chicas se pone nombre era los
chicos suponen spray como que sabes
lamborghinis neón cocaína sabes es como
un bar
a tope
y luego pues claro bien en los noventas
después y nosotros tenemos ya 35 años y
como que hacemos una reflexión de decir
yo quería cambiar el mundo pero me lo he
pasado de fiesta
y ahí está ese bajón sin los 80 será
como estilazo que guardia web en los
momentos de siempre donde ponte una
camisa de franela tranquilito
simple básico la canción sería a ver si
lo tengo por aquí
[Música]
y un perdedor
y eso nos lleva al 2000 no y en los 2000
es como el plan de cuando tengo 40 años
ya es como el planteo que pensamos
cállate y trabaja
buena idea entonces necesitamos música
pues utilizaría no no sé cómo decirlo
práctica para que como ofrezco que no
sabes cómo
[Música]
cuando buscamos simple
el tec no es para gente 40 años curioso
y esto nos lleva al 2010 se va más de 10
en 10 189 tras 2000 2010
y ya no importa esto importa tu hijo que
tiene 5 años
gracias por participar y ese niño de 5
años pues es muy joven todavía no tiene
atención digamos para escuchar música
para discernir un leitmotiv
y lo que le encanta son los memes sabes
como en plan de charlie bit my finger
cnil yann cat cosa como meme ximénez
y es un poco lo que estamos viendo ahora
no como nuevos lenguajes no sabemos un
poco cómo expresar las cosas con
emoticonos estamos de madre
en el 2020
pues el niño tiene 10 años ya ese niño
que es como toda la generación que nos
conlleva no cerrando un poco el círculo
diez años sería igual como en 1940 que
era el jazz máximo como un
y el 2030 pues ya sería de nuevo 15 años
como en 1950
esta teoría pues es nada más para
ilustrar cómo se pueden unificar
sensaciones clásicas con música nueva
gracias
[Aplausos]